previously on TV sins I just want to let
you know that a nun or the big
homecoming game tomorrow
I'm gonna give you guys the day off I'm
gonna cut you a break today
so why don't you make like a tree and
get out of here excuse me could you
spare some change for a phone call who
are they talking about here boys camera
hanging out even in the 90s team shows
were required to start off with
narration I swear if TV existed in the
colonial times some show about George
Washington's adolescence would have
started with mine dad have granted me a
hatchet and you cherry tree totally look
right to strike
I quit boys how they have it so easy oh
you have to pretend you don't notice
them noticing you sure nine oh two one
oh no Meah pioneered the thirtysomething
playing a high school removed but less
than two minutes in my so-called life
says you know what Art's gonna be 40
mother because she wasn't just talking
about my hair she was talking about my
life I had my hair dyed mom jokes
considering the show had to actually pay
someone to create the generic paper
towels logo wouldn't it be more
beneficial to have someone like bounty
sponsor the show or just have the paper
towels out of the packaging
yeah that's in the 90s we just tore open
blocks of cheese and ate them with our
bare hands because we were filthy
animals just begging for a belt with
constipation I cannot bring myself to
eat a well-balanced meal in front of my
mother
it just means too much to her geez talk
about first world problems it's not red
it's crimson glow and it looks amazing
seriously if the show really wanted to
make this kind of parental reaction
believable they could have at least had
her dye her hair blue purple given her a
heroin addiction I'm starting to like
Anne Frank
listen dance can be clueless sometimes
especially when dealing with a teenage
daughter but there's a difference
between clueless and so brain-dead you
mistake Anne Frank for a friend your
child met at school the sad truth is my
breasts have come between us let's try
to contextualize this and assume that
people were more honest and forthcoming
a couple decades ago they had more
hangups or at least acknowledged that
more or
that they were more keenly subversive to
the mechanisms of awkwardness there is
still no end to how casually skeevy this
sequence is tell her not to walk around
in a towel okay no I can't
was it adds an ability to deal with his
daughter's growing up and wearing a
towel around the house the real stuff we
needed on television dramas in 1994
starting to see why this show only
lasted 19 episodes no freedom no privacy
constant surveillance that's what we
need well just wait twenty years
apparently we can all blame the chase
family for the fact that our privacy is
now a thing of the past it could be a
lot worse
sure you could be Ivanka and she could
be cutting class doing drugs having sex
if Tom Irwin is trying to get an award
for creepiest dad from 90s television
he's succeeding with flying colors I'm
in love his name is Jordan Catalano yep
this boy is terrifically good-looking
you can see great things in this dudes
future like totally form a band
that'll feature songs like you know I
guess the one about America and oh
they'll be in really cool movies like
the what about the Brad Pitt and the
replicants and let's just all agree that
Jared Leto peaked right here and move on
yeah I know we're three years away from
chasing Amy coming out but people still
didn't know what the pronoun game was
right against stuff she should little
probably spent hours observing people
lean to get it just right
method actors can we talk about how you
can't tell any of these girls apart
aside from Angela without seeming
nineties this talk about empty threats
isn't this on the front end of the
semester does the yearbook theme have to
be set right the doubt my parents keep
asking how school was it's like saying
how is that drive-by shooting so much
angst and hyperbole also to get this
shot someone had to be way too close to
Claire's Dane's than is legal heavily
discounted 10 things i hate about use
Heath Ledger and she was never seen
again look you're the one that used a
standard serial killer echoey sound
freeze frame fade out so don't play me
show
what what are you quitting Daniel it was
a wash with the pronoun game we're gonna
be wait I thought you liked your book
how does Jos 3ds best Armstrong know
that Angela was quitting the yearbook
she didn't even give her a chance to
answer the question meanwhile this is
Amy Amy forgot to bring it on at the big
game last night Amy yes now set what is
the purpose of plasma sure teaching high
school is rough but if you're lecturing
while a student is sleeping literally
right under your nose and you don't even
mention it you've lost
just go home Artie why do we need Brian
because the League of Nations failed and
why did the League of Nations fail
Oh pick me pick me because they tried to
do cutesy edits where it switches
classrooms mid-sentence and ended up
being more confusing than cover how
would you describe and lucky is that
supposed to be funny Angela these types
of cringy encounters eerily predict my
Twitter timeline because if you made a
book of what really happened could be a
really upsetting book like The Da Vinci
Code
and this TV show is way too okay with
these Anne Frank parallels to high
school life and despite nostalgia TV
shows wrong as hell the lack of media is
destroying America vegan Jamie what is
this a Hyundai Superbowl commercial
holy Sh that's the banned animal back
remember them of course you don't and
yeah we're playing the music even though
we're risking the claim but if we get
one we're getting one from animal bag
this would be their greatest moment
since this episode also a live band
spotlights on a school night this is an
LA or New York City this is a suburb in
Pennsylvania who are these kids
little-known fact teenagers in the 90s
started wearing plaid at such a rate
that this show was often cited as being
solely responsible for the plaid famine
of 1997 dozens died from the inability
to maintain simple necessities of color
cross pattern garments and yet the
producers walk free to this day Jordan
his fights this bites this bites
you come back in here and wash your
mouth out with an animal bag cassette
tape young man so 20 years ago in
dialogue and music like this would play
in shows we all just kind of thought it
was fine and stuff because I kind of
feel like I'm watching a telenovela on
Telemundo right now student gets served
gross at lunchtime cliche so put that by
the way there were beautiful garlic
knots or baked potatoes or something
that looked much better a second ago
that is an insane amount of jello like
the school has just given up and
realized everyone will be high by lunch
cafeteria is the embarrassment capital
of the world apparently someone's never
been to middle fart Denmark school
flossing
you may think I'm gonna send this moment
for the creation of the Claire Danes cry
face but nope I'm gonna take us in off
for how awesomely and disgustingly write
this show gets high school especially
the relationships so there I'm not
crying you're crying I'm not gonna be
sexist enough to suggest that the girls
bathrooms can't be just as nasty as the
boys but I do have to ask the question
is there not a trash can even in here
hey you know what I think I rode to
China's best Armstrong I think well
really nothing just wanted to point out
that she was in the high road to China
which was definitely sick it's about
this girl just obscene phone calls it's
like a job girl six for a good time call
phone sex 1997 phone sex 2017 and
Hathaway on Valentine's Day you're
breaking like 14 different laws name one
no seriously what a stupid thing to say
here I get Brian's trying to give her a
hard time but there are like 14
different lines that could have conveyed
the same thing in a way that at least
coincided with a fragment of reality
there
like kidnapping or something parental
conflict hanging with the wrong crowd
peer pressure underage drinking and
smoking and now a possible statutory
rape can be added to the list of topics
the show crams into its very first
episode I wonder this thing only lasted
19 episodes they ran out of the talk
about another girl just a reminder
Claire Danes was 14 when she shot this
show and Paul Allen here was 21 can you
imagine if the show had actual makeout
scenes with the two of them good thing
that'll never happen
hands house no one was home so why is
the cop leaving her there unattended at
the very least shouldn't suggest that
Angela stay there with her creepily
reading a book up at a tree by
flashlight seriously Brian Krakow might
be the most insane teenage male
character ever created for television
and that's with David silver Dossett
Leary and Xander Harris on the table she
was hiding right and it's other way she
was Thirteen's really is great in this
when she plays this role so
authentically that it works even amongst
the clunky dialogue and soap opera
melodrama around her I just can't finish
my so-called sins without taking at
least one off for her magic and of
course her dad is having an affair as
well because they haven't already landed
up enough soap in this opera it's the
year 2000 that's the theme just what
it'll be like well to save you the
effort the video chain blockbuster will
turn down the offer to buy the company
called Netflix for 50 million a crazy
naked guy will win survivor and the
athletes at the Sydney Olympics will go
through the first 70,000 condoms so fast
that they have to order another 20,000
before the Olympics are over so hope
that helps with the yearbook and all
it's a so-called Wonderful Life
things are about to change around here
recess is over
no we're not the kind of twins who look
like we just finished other sandwiches
that's what I was gonna say the game is
in the afternoon I have to get my hair
done at 5:00 and the dance is at 8:00
I'll be totally wiped out my mother had
not had a hot meal for herself in 15
years
I cannot bring myself to eat a
well-balanced meal in front of my mother
it just means too much to her you wanna
scream at your mother in tears doesn't
seem like a Friday it's Thursday
I need a machine-gunner Jordan its banks
let's go over to grunge explain this
place is dead anyway man you got
everybody there you got your freshman
ROTC guys friends JV jocks so you just
drop your I mean tell me what I did a
lot of pain a little love am I supposed
to feel grateful good mr. Kotter